since the last time i saw you you became
knighted congratulations
actually
we i now address you as sir which is
i've got to think this has got to change
your life
you you can't fly coach you
you can't use public restrooms exactly
it's just this is a big deal it is a big
deal
it's a big deal for me because it was
totally unexpected and
it almost didn't happen because it came
the invitation to accept or not this
honor
came in a brown envelope and it was put
into a plastic shopping bag
with a whole lot of other mail and when
i arrived at my destination that weekend
i put it in the closet and found it 10
days later
wait a minute first of all i can't
believe that's how they notify you
in england that you're going to be
knighted that it just goes out with junk
mail
you know and then you almost didn't open
it
except that it doesn't have written
across its free final offer
yeah just act now
you too could be a knight yes
choose to avoid disappointment uh
it said the cabinet office printed along
the top and i was going through the mail
it was
six o'clock in the morning going on
location but what's this
and and what is it is it a letter saying
uh we would like to invite you to i mean
what does it actually look like i'm
fascinated by this
i think it's a printed letter and my
name is written in at the beginning
dear mr stewart and and then it tells
you and i
i just like in the movies i read it
three times because
i couldn't make sense of it but that
this was directed at me i looked at the
envelope surely it's addressed to the
wrong person
yeah they meant the other patrick
stewart yeah me
and then there is a second piece of
paper
and this literally has two boxes
and you are asked to tick one of them
and it says
yes i accept
or no i do not wait a minute in this
country this is called
jury duty you know
this is uh this is being made a knight
this is a this is a thousand-year-old
tradition and there's two boxes you
checked
uh well it's uh it's better than jury
duty yeah
i mean i i don't know i turned down jury
duty yeah
and i have never done it i don't qualify
here anyway because i'm not a citizen
i'm only a resident alien get the
laughing over about right now
and um do that so it's a it was an
extraordinary honor i was thrilled to
accept it
uh astonished but proud to be joining
the company of
long-time dear friends of mine like ian
mckellen and derek jacoby who have
and of course i grew up yeah yeah
these are terrific actors career actors
and good friends and uh but i grew up
worshiping cedric hardwick so lawrence
olivier said john gilgard sir alec
guinness
you know all these great nights so you
wake up one morning
and you find that you're no longer 14.
you're now 71 and
uh i i'm actually older but i was 71
when i got the knighthood
right that's why over 15 years ago
you look fantastic thank you when i'm
offered a knighthood
as i'm sure mine is in the mail i will
accept it
i will accept it i will accept it as an
american citizen
gracefully gracefully but american
citizens have been awarded
knighthoods and damehood so i see no
reason in fact
i think it's something that should be
insisted on yes thank you
you're gonna take away here